-Our first guest tonight is an
Academy Award- an Emmy-nominated
actor and musician who you know
and love from his work in movies
such as "Thor: Ragnarok"
and "Independence Day"
and his series "The World
According to Jeff Goldblum."
He returns to the "Jurassic"
franchise
in "Jurassic World: Dominion,"
which is in theaters
and IMAX June 10th.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Jeff Goldblum,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Thank you so much.
-This is what -- You know,
we've often talked about
our shared connection to
Pittsburgh,
and I feel like you're wearing
a Steelers-themed sweatshirt.
-That's so funny
you should say that.
I was going to draw your
attention to it if it came up.
Yes. How about that?
Yellow and gold.
And in honor of the day
they will crush
the Green Bay Packers.
-Oh, that's a lovely --
-You see?
-You're very -- Yeah, it's like
V-ing out Green Bay, yes.
-That's right.
-I love it. Very nice.
How are you?
-Look at me. I'm good.
-I think one of the --
[ Laughter ]
Now, I've added a little girl,
but we've always talked
in the past -- we have boys that
are almost the exact same ages.
-Yes, that's right.
How about that?
Yeah, ours is almost seven.
Charlie is,
and then River is five.
-That's fantastic.
-How about that?
And you added of course
eight months ago --
-Yeah, we added a little girl.
Now, this is a question
I have for you
because you're teaching
your boys how to play piano.
-Well, I'm not really, but I'll
tell you all about it, yes.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah.
-But you know how, right?
-Somewhat.
I'm a humble student.
I like to practice, yeah.
-See, because that's the thing.
Like, my wife and I,
neither of us are musical,
so I don't know if we're ready
to take a leap like this with
our children
because neither of us
have any skills.
-Well, it's a good question.
I didn't realize -- I didn't
imagine it when I signed them up
for piano lessons that we would
actually -- it would fall to us
to be the facilitators,
the rehearsal directors
because my parents
did not do that.
And so the answer to your
question is you needn't wait.
You don't have to -- I mean,
they'll have a teacher, right?
And then, I don't know,
it's up to them to kind of --
you can help out if you can.
I'm sure you can early on.
You know how to -- And I believe
the Suzuki method suggests
that the parent kind of learns
along with.
-See, I don't want to do that.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Well, then --
-I feel like the window's closed
'cause here's what I'm thinking.
I feel like if my kids
and I learn at the same time,
they will lap me so quickly with
their, like, with their little
baby fingers that are
growing and learning,
whereas mine are
just getting less.
-Yes, of course.
-Yeah.
-Well, that's our destiny,
isn't it?
The children will go like this
and we go like that
in every way.
My kids already outrun me.
-Yeah.
-You know,
"Dada, here, let's race."
You know, I can't outrace them.
And they wrestle me to
the ground
and beat me into a pulp
whenever they like.
Oh, my gosh.
-It's tough.
Well, let's be honest, Jeff.
We're slightly, I believe,
probably slightly older
than the dads that both of our
kids are friends with, right?
-Not you.
You're younger than springtime.
-I am a little bit older than
the other dads at the school,
and I want to impress that
upon my children.
I'm like, "Don't think you can
wrestle me the way
these children wrestle
their father."
[ Laughter ]
-Really? Really?
-Yeah, I'm like,
"This is a different thing."
-Really? Yeah, yeah.
I know, I know. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is very exciting.
This is gonna be the first time
your kids are going to see
a movie on the big screen
which is "Jurassic."
-Yes, that's true.
This "Jurassic World: Dominion"
movie is coming out tomorrow,
and they've never --
Neither of them have seen
a movie in a movie theater.
-My kids haven't either.
-Ah.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, there was COVID
and we've been selective about
what we wanted to show them,
but that's a whole other
interesting conversation to me,
what movies at what point --
-See, I only --
We only show them this show.
[ Laughter ]
-Good idea.
-Yeah, they don't --
They hate it, but we're like,
"This pays the bills!"
-Exactly. So you're like Malcolm
McDowell in "Clockwork Orange."
-Yeah, very.
Very "Clockwork Orange."
-Yeah, get their eyes open.
-They're much better, you know,
these days obviously.
They're less metal,
but they're very good.
-Of course. Oh, still.
You can pry them open.
Oh, yeah. That's right.
-Are they excited?
Do they know they're going to
see it on a big screen?
-I keep telling them,
yes, and we're going --
I say, "It's going to be loud."
We're going to see
an IMAX thing,
as you commented
in the monologue --
"and it's going to be loud
and it's kind of scary."
But, you know, you know --
we'll see what happens.
-Have you ever small-screen
shown them the original?
-Yeah, I did a little bit ago
this last year or two,
"Jurassic Park"
and the second one.
And the little one was kind of,
"Oh, no," duh-duh-duh-duh.
But they were into it and now
they can't get enough of it.
They're very -- Well, any TV
really is mesmerizing
and addictive immediately.
-I don't know if you had this
thing because we waited so long
to introduce films to them
that we were showing them
"Paddington," you know?
And all those movies, there's
a moment where, you know,
the hero is, you know,
Paddington gets kicked out of
the house for some bull[bleep],
let's be honest.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not familiar with any
Paddington.
-Yeah, but, like, Paddington's
out in the rain and my kids,
both my kids are sobbing.
And I wanted to be like, "Oh."
I said to my wife, I'm like,
"We haven't, like, taught them
about movies.
We got to be like,
'Look, Paddington
is going to be fine.'"
[ Laughter ]
-That's very interesting,
though.
No, I think that's emotionally
sophisticated, isn't it?
I remember the first movie that
I ever cried,
that made me cry was
a Jackie Gleason movie.
He played a kind of a mute --
"Gigot."
But I think that was
a little later.
I think that's so interesting.
But I don't think Charlie
has ever cried at a movie.
The older one, although there's
much wailing and gnashing
of teeth, as you can imagine.
the emotional roller coaster
is ever present.
-I mean, I should say that
I love my kids' sensitivity.
It's a wonderful thing.
-Sensitivity?
-Yeah, it's great.
I also want to be like,
"When you're watching these
movies with your friends..."
-Yeah.
-"...you got to keep
your [bleep] together when
Paddington --"
[ Laughter ]
-No. Don't say that.
-"When Paddington goes outside,
you can't be like, 'Aah!'
'cause the other kids -- the
other kids know he's coming --
-Yeah, yeah.
-This isn't like --
It's gonna be like, "Is this the
movie where Paddington dies?"
I'm like, "That doesn't --
That movie doesn't exist."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, again, I don't know about
Paddington, but -- but --
-You're being very negative
about Paddington today.
-No, I'm not.
I just want to be honest.
But they've seen me
cry at movies, though.
I kind of --
-Oh, really?
-Yes, yes. And sometimes
I get "boo-hoo-hoo."
I get very vociferous
and, you know, they're a little
bit interested, and then
sometimes they go,
"Dada, stop it, stop it."
-Oh, yeah.
-They kind of do that.
-I will say, since I had kids,
I cry all the time.
Like, I feel like I'm more
sensitive now as well.
-Well, I know.
I mean, it just breaks your --
It opens up -- cracks your heart
way open.
-Yeah.
-They do things, just looking at
them, looking at pictures
and things, I can --
-Yeah, well, you and me both.
I have a lot more questions
for you.
Will you stick around?
-Yes, I want to very badly.
-Alright, great. We'll be
right back with more
from Jeff Goldblum.